anderson silver knights have a home to
call their very own
sports director chris matthews joining
us now with today's grand opening of
lifeguard arena chris well thank you
donation speaking of kiddos there'll be
a lot of kiddos inside this one right
here yeah first
you had the city national now you have
two sheets of ice now in the south end
of the valley two more
in henderson one of the goals of knights
owner bill foley was when he bought this
club
let's bring youth hockey to the valley
that's what he's certainly doing making
good on those promises that he made
of course and he's making good on his
word to build winners and how about this
the kids will really enjoy this they'll
learn hockey they'll continue to skate
and enjoy the sport of hockey that's
what he's doing today was a grand
opening to lifeguard arena it's similar
in every way to city national
out there in summerlin fact truth be
told the henderson facility
might be a little nicer now hey they
learned how to make it better right and
the knights have accomplished that goal
with the grand opening today
obviously for the guys it's good for the
travel aspect that you mentioned and
you know for the organization to keep a
closer eye on their uh their young guys
and how they're doing how they're
progressing how they're developing
that sort of stuff and uh obviously
again like you said it's
it's nice for those guys who you know do
go back and forth a little bit where
they can
just make a drive up 2 15 and that's all
they have to do they don't apply
anywhere so that's that's
i think a big thing for the guys as well
all right the team yesterday revealed
the jerseys for the silver knights and
now they're available to purchase
outside
while inside the livery we should say ah
this will be the home to the silver
knight
so the silver knights will practice at
lifeguard arena and for the first two
years they play at the orleans arena
their season is scheduled to begin in
february david
just right around the corner all right
chris thanks we are just